there's something there i was trying to
like visualize a scenario where it would
be okay but it's not
it's not okay and the problem is liam is
thinking right now if he takes that
bishop
if black's pawn takes that bishop the
white queen will simply recapture and
checkmate is coming but if you don't
take back that bishop
you're actually two pawns down with
black so you're two pawns down and
you're getting attacked
and you're about to lose even more
material most likely
to stave off that attack no this is
hopeless
no chance and wow this sudden sudden
flurry of moves okay he takes a rook
because he didn't want to just kind of
suffer for nothing you might as well
suffer
with something in your hand with a rook
in your hand but i see a few ways
i see a czech mates and now the queen
will step forward the king
must retreat and either the queen will
come to the g7 square checkmate or the
knight will come to the g7 square
and it's over wesley saw with the white
pieces he wins
the first game in the final against liam
leliam
he rushes off okay getting back to his
computer does he want to look over this
now